what's happening you bad [__]
it's wednesday august the 11th
the joint is brought to you by
stamps.com
this summer has been great for me so far
you know what i'm saying between the
little league
the barbecues little [__] parties i'm
having a great time i'm enjoying life's
little pleasures
but i'll tell you what i don't enjoy is
going back to a [__] post office
with stamps.com you can skip the post
office and save money on postage send
letters ship packages anytime anywhere
right from your computer
buy print ship it's that simple with
stamps.com
you pay a whole lot less get discounts
up to 40 percent
from the post office rates and up to 66
percent from ups listen to me my wife
has been using stamps.com
for the last 10 years and i [__] love
it she doesn't have to go to the post
office she prints out the label smacks
it on the [__] box puts it in front
of the door and the mailman picks it up
they have letters whatever you got you
got a small business
stamps.com is a must-have
print the us postage for any letter
package a class of mail it's no wonder
over a million small businesses have
already signed up
with stamps.com stop wasting your time
going to the post office
go to stamps.com instead it's no risk
use promo code joey to get a special
offer that includes
a four-week trial plus free postage and
a digital scale with stamps.com there
are no long-term commitments
or contracts go to stamps.com click on
the microphone on the top of the home
page and type in joey j-o-e-y
that stamps dot com
promo code joey never go to the post
office again with stamps.com
the joint is also brought to you by my
personal favorite c b d lion when it
comes to cbd nobody does it like the
lion whether it's the roland whether
it's the cream
the kinesiology tape the bath balls the
[__] vapor pens
cbd lion will get the cbd to you
i love the new cbd gummies with
melatonin the [__] slumber berry is
tremendous the mixed is tremendous
listen to me go to cbd lion read about
the third party lab results and get on
board use promo code joey or church and
get 20 off delivered to your house
cbd lion nobody does it like them and
now it's time
for the [__] joint [__] smokers
let's do this [__]
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
it's wednesday the 11th of august eight
more days and i'll be here a
[__] year that's a fast [__]
year ladies and gentlemen unbelievable
it's a beautiful day to be alive i've
had a great [__] week
so far i went to the dentist monday
it looks like in a couple weeks this
tooth the little fang
is coming the [__] out and they're gonna
fix that whole piece there and hopefully
this infection will be the [__] over
i don't know what caused it you know i
haven't eaten [__]
strange ass in 21 [__] years so
usually when you have like a cold sore
or something you're like i ate some
[__] rotten ass
the other day but that hasn't been the
case of me i've been a married man for
21 years so who the [__] knows where
this [__] little fang
got [__] infected from uh the
family's good been having a great time
sunday night i went to this uh
the town had like this [__] outdoor
little festival you know
it rained up but [__]
i said what the [__] it's just a little
bit of rain
let's go down there and see what's
cracking
went down there it was [__]
tremendous
kids were all over the place [__]
running cops were there
[__] talk to a bicycle cop for a
little while he listens to the podcast
it's [__] crazy when a cop comes up
to you he's like i listen to your
podcast you're like really you're gonna
arrest me now cause
[__] he was looking at me all weird
but it happens but it was weird they had
like a band they had food trucks
they had fireworks and i realized sunday
night at 58 that jews don't like [__]
fireworks man
they lose their [__] minds when
fireworks go up i never seen so many
people leave a [__] thing so fast
once the fireworks started going i saw
all the yarmulkers walking the [__] out
of there it was crazy they do not like
[__] fireworks i was talking to lee
last night on the phone i'm like lee
what is it with jews and fireworks they
do not like [__] fireworks because
that's funny i don't like fireworks
either so it's true jewish people don't
like he goes i wonder why i goes maybe
it reminds you of germany i don't
[__] know they just don't [__]
like it maybe [__] fireworks were
done in germany i have no [__] idea
but i've never seen so many jews leave i
was talking to one he's like i gotta get
the [__] out of here michael what the
[__] don't jewish people like fireworks
i guess not
but anyway
[__] i never [__] realized that i'm
58 i grew up with a bunch of jewish
people and i never really noticed that
till the other [__] night that
it's all over once that first [__]
grenade goes off in the air
they're done they're like [__] it this
ain't the gaza strip we're getting the
[__] out of here this is [__] scary
here who gives a [__] we're having a
good time on a wednesday morning
[__]
wash your helmets we're going launching
today [__]
but that's about it man i'm having a
good [__] time i'm feeling a lot
better
you know i've been writing lately and
i'll tell you what i have
me and mike were talking about tom
morello before
the tomarello's knowledge of [__] uh
music is incredible you know i've always
been a big fan of rage against the
machine
and one day me joe rogan and eddie were
eating that some [__] we were at uh
on fairfax and sunset and they used to
be there's a starbucks there
across the street from that breakfast
joint i forget what the [__] the name of
it is and next to the starbucks used to
be a mexican joint now it's a hamburger
place so when i was in l.a was a
hamburger place and i'll never forget
one day [__] we're inside getting the
food me and joe we come out
and eddie bravo is sitting there
with tom morello
and i had to do everything i could to
[__] control myself
because the inner [__] in me came out
right because like i don't give a [__]
about movie stars i don't give a [__]
about famous comedians but a musician
like if i see joe perry i have a heart
attack
like especially guitar players like i
just [__] cream all over myself but i
didn't ask him for a picture of nothing
[__] i didn't
[__] out on him or whatever i sat there i
said hello
and i just talked to him and we just
talked about different music i mean i
didn't
say that much because i was kind of
embarrassed eddie did all the talking
which is [__] scary i mean he was
talking about kiss and [__] it was great
but uh
i become a fan of tom morello's with you
know his radio show on sirius and i got
to tell you something his [__]
knowledge of music is phenomenal
just now mike was telling me that he did
a copy of another brick on the wall i
heard highway to hell the other day he
did a [__] thing a highway to hell
the other day on the patreon i played
[__] uh voodoo chow it was either
jimi hendrix's version or [__]
tomarello's version i mean
tom morello's aptitude for music is
phenomenal i don't know if it's a double
degree he has double major
but i was telling mike before like it
really helps to have that aptitude when
you bump into those big time musicians
you could tell they have it's like
bumping into a fighter when you bump
into a ufc fighter you could goof on
them and stuff they're very
they're very calm because they have
nothing to prove
you know you expect the fighter to be
like
nah not even [__] close a real
top-notch fighter
doesn't act that way and a real musician
when you're around the re you know you
ever see like those skinny guys that
have like the tight leather pants and
they're like full heavy metal guys all
[__] day and once they get on stage
they suck dick you know the guys that
you see on a plane with the [__]
guitar walk on like really check the
[__] guitar [__] sucker no they bring
on the plane they put in the overhead
compartment all those dudes are [__]
fugazis you never see tom morello with a
[__] carrying his guitar around even
though he's part of the 20 000 hour rule
whatever for [__] guitar players but
just talking to him that day gave me a
sense and listening to him on serious
holy [__] the way he described music
but what the point i was getting to that
is and i know you people are going to
look at me and say this guy's [__]
out of his mind
i'll tell you what man i know a lot
about [__] comedy
it's really weird how scary it is to me
when i write out
what stand up is like when i read like
i've been just
i was thinking that maybe i should put a
book out about your stand-up comedy
like my experiences all that [__]
instead of a book about my life like
that's the second thing i'm looking at
right now so i was just making notes the
other night
and it's weird that it all comes back to
the first time i shot marin the first
time i shot maron was the first time i
realized
that i was really [__] experienced to
do whatever the [__] you gave me would
stand up
and then i remember shooting this is not
happening afterward and looking at the
first one and going jesus christ when it
comes to comedy i know what i'm doing
like i raised my voice at the right time
you know when you write a joke you have
to look at the words and see how you
structured them it's all this [__]
thing and after 30 years you learn
so [__] much you know
and it's uh
it's just
a great feeling to know that you're good
at something like now that i'm just
doing a podcast these days like i don't
feel like i'm good at [__] you know i've
been
struggling the last
year you know because i don't feel like
i'm good enough especially without doing
stand-up and that's what was bothering
me that i'm so [__] good at stand up
i have so much knowledge
about stand up from from lenny bruce to
richard pryor to [__]
you know jonathan winters i mean i i
listened to all those [__] albums i
did the work
and it really pays off you know
i was telling you a couple weeks ago i
took a guitar lesson from rudy and i
[__] he gave me an anxiety attack
he was like a drill sergeant he knew so
many things about
me you know music that even my like
regular guitar player my regular guitar
teacher is very good he's a [__]
shredder
but he doesn't have the knowledge that
rudy has even though rudy's a [__]
bass player it's just so [__] weird
anyway
we have a guest today it's wednesday i
always do a little zoom on wednesday to
break it up from you guys i give you an
ear beating on mondays
and then wednesday we [__] ease it
off so i give you another beating the
following monday
this guest today i really have enjoyed
his friendship he is my friend i really
have to tell you this
because it's been really weird one day
josh wolfe reached out to me and said
robert eiler wants to be on the podcast
i'm like aj and i almost [__] had a
heart attack
i'm like are you [__] serious and he
came into the office and he was a
complete gentleman
then i think we talked a couple times on
the phone and then i did his podcast
before i left with jamie lynn and one
night when i was here like in august
after i moved into this house it had to
be september
one night he just checked up on me and i
was like blown the [__] away
that this young kid was checking up on
me see how i was doing and he said to me
that
he goes the reason why i called you and
then he called again like after me and
mike started doing the joint
and one day he texted me one night i was
sitting on the couch or just watching tv
with my wife
and i got a text from robert eiler and
he goes
how can these people
pay all this money to put a tv show
together and you're just as entertaining
talking to the air all by yourself
because i can't figure that out
so ever since that time i got you know i
called him up i didn't text him back and
we had a long talk about podcasts
and about comedy and about all this [__]
and he's just a great [__] guy
so uh without further ado
i bring you mr robert owlette known as
aj from the sopranos enjoy [__]
thank you sir
robert what's the story what's going on
brother how are you my man
what's been going on
it's good to see you nothing man just uh
you know life still kind of feels like
it's on pause
in a way a little bit but uh
yeah i i don't mind it you know i'm i'm
chilling how's uh how's jersey jersey's
good man i a lot better than what i
thought it would be
it's uh it's changed a lot 30 [__]
years that i've been gone
but it's a good change you know it's
still good
i'm in a [__] uh child neighborhood
i'm in a big time kid neighborhood
which is good for my daughter shitty for
me
you know i'm a [__] old man in this
neighborhood but it's still great how's
la treating you
at least i for me like there's new york
and then everywhere else is kind of all
the same i don't really care where i am
you know if i'm in new york i love it
but
i'm just at the point where i'm like how
many i did like two winters away from
new york in a row and then trying to do
a winter there back i was like what the
[__] am i doing here like i just i
couldn't uh
figure it out but i i got uh i got
family in jersey over by uh by rutgers
and they love it
was i say to you how you miss jamie
yeah i miss jamie she moved to austin
she went when uh
when everybody left but she's loving it
her kids you know the big thing was like
she was like my kids got to go to
[__] school like you know the kids in
la like weren't going to school they'd
go to school for two days then it would
all shut down again because it somebody
would get coveted or there'd be word or
somebody would covet or it would just
shut down because nobody got coveted and
it was like
she's like i can't i can't keep doing
this to my kids like you know when when
a kid is you know one of her kids is two
years old three years old she's like not
being around other kids is like you feel
like it's
you're doing such a disservice to your
kid you know it was a shitty [__]
feeling
when the pandemic first hit
it was wild seeing my daughter
slipping
i saw a kid that
her first grade teacher wasn't her
kindergarten teacher she didn't like her
first grade teacher i could tell because
she would talk a lot about the teacher
at home she never mentioned the first
grade teacher
so she wasn't having a good time already
in the first grade and then the pandemic
hit
and i could tell she was going backwards
like mentally
you know i saw my child getting sad she
didn't know you know you can't explain
to a
seven-year-old why they can't go to
school
for a couple days she thought she had
done something wrong
you know so it was kind of like it
wasn't good and we were taken to places
and
people were staying away from us you
know we understood what was going on but
children really didn't understand and
it weighed a lot it weighed so much on
her that when that [__]
announced garcetti that there was no
school in l.a
i went and got a house three or four
days later
like that announcement was made july
12th
and i knew my daughter had to go to
school i knew we had to get the [__] out
of there
the people had fallen apart around us i
mean nobody really knew so i'm not mad
at anybody
nobody really knew the rules do you
remember when they were telling you to
wipe your mail
yeah like the [__] mail and [__]
nobody [__] knew you know so
you have to now we know more we you know
we see what the [__] going on but in
the beginning nobody knew dick
and it was scary for people and you know
nobody was going out
we couldn't get play dates outside it
was just me her and my wife and a
[__] tree
there was a tree in noho park and she
would climb it and get off it after a
month she got sick of that [__] tree
so
i could tell that yeah you just get sick
of the [__] trees she couldn't even
look at the [__] tree no more
and i couldn't blame her you know and
that's why i made the move you look at
your children they're like they weren't
uh
this is not good and the numbers are
going up again
and parents are sitting here going are
we going to take this beating again this
year i mean there's a lot of parents i
know la's expecting it
i know new york is expecting it [__]
texas the numbers are blowing up but
this is what they're telling you
robert if you're not there like when
they tell you [__] every day that things
are going bad then you talk to somebody
there
and they're like things are all right ov
i don't know what they're talking about
so
who knows what the [__] is going on
all we could do is control what we do
right now i guess
and that's the thing i think
like
more people need to be comfortable with
saying like yeah i don't [__] know
we're like you know i'm not on social
media but i hear all these like anybody
on twitter is like if you even say like
oh you know i i got a sore arm from the
vaccine they're like you're an
anti-vaxxer you're this bra and they're
like no the person's like no i just said
i got the vaccine and here's what it's
like
you know the same way you said at first
when it came out they said all this
stuff and then they said this and then
they said that and even up until you
know
four months ago it was like if you got
the vaccine you can't spread it this so
what we know is
we don't we don't know right we don't
know what's gonna happen we don't know
what's going on so just being able to be
like hey yeah i don't know like i'm not
really sure i think that's what we need
to do more instead of everybody like
you know like like four months ago
people were yelling at you if you didn't
get the vaccine like you you're
spreading it you're spraying and now
that's different it's like hey maybe
let's just like
we don't know like we don't know what
the [__]
is is going on and that's i think
i don't know man i don't think enough
people are comfortable being like i
don't [__] know like because that's
how i feel you know with with all of it
in the last year and a half and
i was just dating this girl uh you know
we stopped talking because she
you know she's like oh i want to have
kids and the next we when we met she
said i wasn't sure if i want kids i said
i wasn't sure if i want kids and then
her sister had a baby
and she came back from seeing the baby
and she's like i want kids and i got a
three year timeline like i i want kids
after she like held the baby and saw her
family around the baby and i totally got
it i was like yeah i get it
but uh
and like after this last year and have i
told her i'm like i don't know like i i
how how after
for me like after seeing how life was in
this last year and a half for me
planning three years ahead with somebody
who i met two months ago i'm like this
seems crazy to me like how the [__] can
we do this so we just you know we kind
of went our our separate ways but it's
you know i don't know i hear people
making plans for five years from now oh
here's what i'm going to be doing that
i'm like what i don't know
three i just decided another [__]
year lease i'm like i i feel crazy
putting this pen to paper saying i'll
i'll be here another year how the [__]
do i know it's just crazy it all feels
nuts you know i gave up i lived day to
day
i gave up i know what i want to do and i
know what i don't want to do you know
i took an acting job at the end of the
month
even though the numbers are going high
you know what are you gonna do stay the
[__] home all the time
you gotta have some type of contact you
gotta be out there and you gotta work a
little bit you know and uh
when i took the job i'm like what am i
[__] crazy i'm like no this is what
we do and we got to keep pushing
if not you know they're just going to
keep selling fear to you
and you know if you go online right now
they're selling fear they're selling
the vaccine that they're pushing the
numbers they're telling you and you know
what i'm [__] sick of it
like i don't even want to read it no
more i got the vaccine i got a j and j
shot between you and i i don't even know
if there was anything in there i think
it was [__] water with
[__] uh powder you know for all i
[__] know it was johnson and johnson
powder they put some water in there to
make it look a little weird and they
[__] shot in my arm on
i didn't get sick i didn't get i had a
headache for a few days
people saying to me you know i've had
some health issues
the last year and people like do you
think it's the vaccine
no i would love to [__] blame the
vaccine
but i was sick before i [__] took the
shot you know i had anxiety and my tooth
was [__] up and i had knee surgery so
it had nothing to do with the vaccine it
was just
my anxiety was from last august you know
my [__] dental work was from last
year in california my gums got swollen
so i i don't know what the [__] happened
with whether that people gave me [__]
for getting the vaccine
and i but i knew it was going to turn
into what's going on now they're
threatening people you know i saw
something
last night where just a thing i went to
check a score on yahoo or some [__]
and it said
uh you know you're going to lose money
at work if you don't get vaccinated that
that what the [__] are you talking about
so we're not going to get paid our worth
because we're not vaccinated i mean and
i know this is [__] these are just
people writing articles
and stupidity but that's where we're
going so
i just wanted to get the vaccine get it
out of the way
and i'm happy i did i don't know if i'll
get another shot because
it doesn't [__] matter
all these unvaccinate all these
vaccinated people are getting the delta
variant so what and now they're going to
develop a booster in two weeks
just like that just to [__] so all
this sounds fishy
i don't want to say it's fake because
look what happened to the people that
said this is [__] like ted nugent
and all these people there's no covert
than a week later like [__] i got hit by
a truck there's coving
make up your [__] mind [__]
there's not so i don't want to put covet
down but
i just say i don't know what the [__] is
going on that's it
yeah that's it that's the only thing i'm
[__] secure about right now you know
i don't
i don't [__] know and i i think
i think people
you know like i i see i know people
who've gotten the shot i know people
who don't get the shot and i'm like yeah
i understand like it's it's this whole
thing of like how people don't
understand and then i i know somebody
else
who got
the
uh vaccine
him
and his wife
got coveted uh
three months after they got the vaccine
and you know five days later they had a
trip booked like an international trip
and they were like well we got our
[__]
our uh
our passport our vaccine passport so
let's go and they [__] got they got
on the plane and they went you know i
don't even want to say where they went
but they went to every oh they're in
[__] shops and taking pictures on
instagram and this and they're [__]
got covet
you know so it's like it's and then and
then at the same in the same breath
people tell you like oh you know
you're the the non-vaccinated are bad
for doing that and it's just like listen
i i
i'm not against getting the shot
i i just i didn't get the shot because i
saw the numbers of people
who
have had covet already and what happens
uh and that you know from from what i
understand and listen i'm not a very
smart guy but from what i understand the
numbers if you've already had covet
are not very bad
uh
if if you happen to get it again i have
asthma so i take this uh like inhaled
steroid every day and and studies
actually came out where they said
because of that inhaled steroid
uh
it's the virus actually isn't as bad for
you because at first
when i heard about covet i didn't leave
my [__] apartment for a month because
of the asthma and everything i'm like oh
this thing is gonna [__] if this gets
me i'm done and then like a study came
out where they said people who take the
inhaled steroid actually i don't even
know i'm you know i'm
not even smart enough to know exactly
the words of how they put it it's not
like you're immune obviously but it's
you uh
you know
it's it's not
as
uh
serious maybe i don't even want to say
the wrong words you know and and cause
somebody who has asthma to then think
that they're safe from [__] covet
because you're not but it's just you
know the the numbers are already
you know low we know with people who get
uh who die from it and stuff like that
and then
on top of it i've already had it and on
top of that i got
i take a steroid every day and i'm like
you know what i'm just not i don't i
don't want to get covered have covid and
then take the shot and then [__] two
years later they come out with like oh
everybody who got [__] clove it has
to worry about this and everybody who
got the shot has to worry about this if
you got both you got to worry about this
i'm like i just you know i also
i don't have a nine to five you know i'm
not worried about uh
spreading it to my co-workers or this
kind of thing and
most of the people i know got the shot
or they're not were they understand the
risk of
not getting it so i just but
i would never push on someone to not get
the shot or to get the shot i tried to
take in as much information as i could
and at the end of the day i understood
that i'm taking a risk and i decided uh
i i haven't got it yet i don't i'm not
saying like i'll never get the shot i
don't know but just as of now
i i have and then i also have
things that happen to people in my
family that i wouldn't even because of
how crazy [__] is now i wouldn't even
want to share it because i don't want
people [__] coming after me like
you're [__] anti-vaccine or this
because i'm not you know i'm not at all
but i just heard you know two things
happen to
people in my family and i was like i
don't you know and it's
who know and then but it's one of those
things where it's like maybe that would
have happened to them anyway you know
you you can never prove it and this so
again it's like
i don't i i would never say like i made
the right decision anybody who got the
shot is dumb or maybe people who aren't
getting the shot done the whole thing is
i don't [__] know you know
with me i thought about one thing i i
heard of somebody who got
a shot and it they got sick
i really do have a dear friend
that his sister took the shot and ended
up spiraling out of control
she had to have heart surgery and [__]
i thought about that before i went to
get the shot and then i thought about
something else you ready for this one
robert
how many [__] drugs have we done
how much coke have i [__] done you
know if that coke it's made in the
jungle people step on the [__] leaves
you know some little colombian kid with
dirty feet steps on the [__] leaves
god knows what i got already inside me
between the pills the reefer
the cocaine the [__] angel dust when
i was 16.
we already put a bunch of wild [__] into
your body what's one more [__] wild
thing
to calm people down and to come you give
me peace of mind you know it was just
peace of mind for me but i'm seeing
these people going you know my body's a
temple your body's not a temple i did
blow it you're [__] ten years ago and
you were [__] eating rocks off the
[__] floor walking around on your
hands and knees
you know when you do those [__] when
you get a surgery and you do those
oxycontins or whatever the [__] they
give you do you have any idea what you
put in your [__] body
no
you know when you do a [__] xanax or
a [__] klonopin or whatever the [__]
you're doing do you have any idea no
then what the [__] the difference
take a chance columbus did you know what
i'm saying every time you do a line of
coke when you do a line of [__] coke
you might have a heart attack
right or wrong when you [__] do a
line of speed you you know
so
that's how i looked at it with all this
[__] up [__] we all ate a bad piece of
ass we've all had
[__] vd and herpes and the whole
[__] thing what's a shot of some
[__] water with powder in it to make
you feel better that's what i thought
about that's what i was thinking about
with all the [__] drugs i did i'm
gonna sit here and [__] talk [__]
about a vaccine i've been snorting
vaccines for 30 [__] years and now i
want to worry about my body's a temple
your body's a [__] disaster
your body's a [__] disaster you eat
potato chips you eat nachos from [__]
doritos you eat mcdonald's and you're
worried about a [__] vaccine you
[__] so
sorry about that i got a little [__]
caught up there
because that's what i was telling myself
you know like i'm not gonna get the
vaccine after all the coke you put in
your body you swam in the hudson
you know what i'm saying
you [__] breathed in harlem you know
you inhaled one of these farts
you're in no danger you're gonna [__]
die anyway anyway you put it we're all
gonna [__] die so cut this [__] make
up your mind if if you wanna do a line
of coke and you feel [__] vaccinated
then so be it i don't give a [__] what
you do you know it was so crazy when i
was doing coke robin i'd do like coke
for three days and then i'd eat sushi
and just because i ate sushi and ate
something like healthy i was like [__]
there's nothing wrong with me sure
there's something wrong with you you're
snorting coke you're [__] putting
straws in your [__] nose you know
when you put a dollar bill in your nose
you get hepatitis c so now you don't
want to shoot the [__] vaccine that
give me a break will you just shoot the
[__] vaccine
and not only doing all the drugs we've
done but also
where we've done it like i i've done so
much coke off of like the back of a
toilet you know or just like disguise
like the [__] particles that were
that i was sniffing up on while people
are taking a [__] next to me and like i
remember one time
we were in line to go to the bathroom
and i knew the guy in front of me he was
like a party promoter for [__]
forever and uh he comes out of the stall
and he goes i left something in there
for you you know so i'm like oh perfect
you know i look on top of where like
that not on top of the toilet tank but
where like the toilet paper is there's
just a [__] mound of coke
and i'm like all right so i do a bunch
of it i take a piss
uh and then all of a sudden i'm like
what the f i'm just like i felt kind of
dizzy or whatever
and uh it was k it was special k but i i
thought it was [__] uh cocaine and i
[__] walked i was because i i did an
amount thinking it was cocaine you know
if i knew it was k i probably still
would have did it but i just would have
done a lot less you know and i was
[__] i was it's like you're instantly
in uh
uh with fear and loathing in las vegas
you know when the camera's like right
here and everything is like he's all
[__] crazy and you're and it's so
crazy because k is one of those only
drugs where like i was just talking to
my friend six minutes ago and was like
totally fine and i'm like hey i'm gonna
go take a piss and i come back on
another [__] planet you know so
not only am i doing
drugs i don't even know what they were
but i'm doing it off of a [__] toilet
tank that probably had or a toilet paper
[__] holder that probably has [__] on
it and this or whatever but
another thing i thought about is you
know in these last eight years i haven't
put [__] in like i'm at [__] whole
foods and i'm like if oh that's not
organic chicken [__] that like i you
know so in my head there's part of me
that's like man i've i've done so
well these last
[__] eight years i'm like i want i
don't even know how my body would react
to to something you know to [__] do
and draw i think about that show like
man i
it's kind of crazy to people like when i
hear how many people are like
on the wagon for so long and then they
go off and like i could understand
something setting somebody off when
people are just like yeah i don't know i
had 12 years and then it just you know i
went to the bar and i started then i'm
like holy [__] like
it's it's [__] wild because you know
i understand death or you know divorce
or something with your children and
people are like i couldn't cope i went
to this but there's some people who go
so long and they just they're like yeah
i don't know it was a tuesday and i felt
like having one you know
so you've been sober for eight years now
yeah so i uh
i i stopped everything i haven't done
like hard drugs in or drinking really in
like eight years but uh
the xanax i had to go see like i
couldn't quit xanax on my own everything
else i i could quit on my own but uh the
the percocets took me a while like
painkillers took me a while but the
xanax i couldn't even do on my own it
was
xanax was the [__] craziest trying to
stop like you know i i never wanna like
uh be little people's [__] addictions
or this but when
for just for me i can only talk about my
story like
quitting
uh
opiates for me was a joke compared to
quitting
uh
xanax because opiates felt like
it was willpower xanax felt like i was
gonna die like i i was it was crazy it
was like i was falling out of a plane
just sitting on my couch like that
that's how it felt like it was like
and you're just [__] sitting there
you know where where with opiates for me
it was just
it was that feeling [__] sick and
feeling like [__] and and
and and i had stopped doing them before
so i knew like
oh if i just get through these [__]
you know three days or however long i
didn't [__] sweat my balls out and
but like
for me opiates the way it felt is like
like you would lay in bed and it would
feel like your bed was covered in sand
you know or like just ev everything like
you'd be like oh i'm standing up i want
to sit down you'd sit down you think i
want to stand up if you were uh thirsty
and you're drinking something by the
when you start drinking like i'm not
thirsty it was like the [__]
the opposite and it was annoying in this
but man xanax was like
xanax was i if i had to quit
[__]
xanax again or be like tortured by the
taliban like i think i'd
pick like you know i don't again i'm
always worried about saying like you
know i don't want people who are like my
brother was [__] tortured by the
taliban you piece of [__] like you know
what like that's not you want your
[__] eyelids cut off or whatever but
it's just
when i think of that [__]
trying to stop xanax and you because it
has it almost like it had nothing to do
with me like i had no control
over what was going on and i saw
this specialist and uh
it's crazy it's crazy when you go to
like therapists or specialists and you
have these
issues in your head that for years
you're like no one understands my
[__] problem that these problems are
such a big deal this and you tell this
doctor and he's heard it so many times
and he's just like here's what you got
to do like you know you do this you do
that like you'll be fine in you know six
months or three months or two weeks
whatever your issue and you and like
just that alone
is like oh [__] like
a lot of other people have dealt with
this before and they're okay this guy
has a [__]
seems to have the answer and then uh
yeah he just you know
some of the first [__] he did was he's
like you can't
take xanax whenever you want he's like
the first thing you got to do is you got
to get on a [__] schedule so he put
me on a schedule he's like whatever
you're taking now the amount of
milligrams a day don't change it he's
like just take
that that same amount but you got to be
hey i take it every day at eleven
three
[__] five whenever but but it'll keep
you
on a [__] certain kind of level where
now he's like the way you take it now is
you wait until you feel like you need it
so you're really low and then as soon as
you take it you bounce back up to high
and then and then you you're just
counting down the hours again until you
need it again and you're bouncing back
up he's like you got to do
even if you don't feel like you needed
nothing you're just you're you're taking
it your body's getting used to it this
and then
i don't it took me a long [__] time
i'd be making it up if i said the number
now but a year a year and a half or
whatever but i just slowly went down
from like i was only taking three
milligrams a day but i had taken it
every day for
i don't know
seven years six years or some [__]
and uh
as soon as as soon as like getting low
wasn't so hard but it was getting off
like when it was like all right here's
the [__]
you know what happened i'm so like
[__] stubborn and like irish and an
idiot that
i it was taking me forever to finally
quit and like not take you know i think
i was taking like still
half a milligram to go to bed or
whatever because i was like i can't do
it without this i can't whatever and
i went away to la for a little bit and
and i was the guy that i was seeing he
was he was charging like i had insurance
or something he was tr it was like 300
was the thing and
and when i had insurance it was paying
for it and then that sag [__] dropped
me because we don't make any money from
residuals or anything so i uh
uh sag drops me and i i go to the guy
and i go listen i i can't pay you 300
out of pocket like i'm i'm not doing it
you know so
what either i stopped seeing you or what
he goes well we could do a 150 a session
i go great thank you
so i'm seeing them a couple times more i
go to la for a little bit to work on
this thing
i come back
and uh i see him and i leave the office
and i get a [__] bill for 300
and i hit him up i go hey like i guess i
don't know if you forget or whatever we
were doing 150 and he was like oh no you
you you went away and came back
so now it's uh 300 again
and that was it i was like [__] this
[__] piece of [__] i was like i'm i'm
never taking a [__] xanax ever again
just so i never have to [__] see this
guy ever again and that night was the
first night ever
i went without a zan and i remember i
was sitting up in my bed just [__]
staring at the wall like
internally shaking you know like i felt
like i was shaking because i was like
angry but also i was like i'm just this
is the first night where i'm not gonna
do it and that was
again
all these numbers in your head get so
mixed up because i'm like oh this is
when i stopped drinking this is when i
stopped doing [__] blow this is when
i stopped taking [__] ecstasy this is
this but it was you know
somewhere i think like right around or
right after my 30th birthday so that'd
be like six years ago or
whatever and the only i took like two
xanax since then it was when i uh got on
a plane and besides that i haven't
[__] touched it i don't want it
because what i think what i personally
believe is
eventually the xanax becomes the thing
that's given you the anxiety
that's what i went through because i
didn't take them until the pandemic
started
then i started eating those footballs
like they said one every four [__]
hours
i was blasting one to get in the [__]
car
and then i got here
and it was duck mckagan
from guns n roses who told me you're
gonna have a problem
and i looked into it when i moved here
and that's when i started tapering and
stuff and then for the surgery i just
went off to xanax
and after about a week i started feeling
weird
and i called the buddy of mine he goes
yeah you have to tape her off
so
that [__] xanax was actually pushing
the anxiety it's called anxiety rebound
or something like that
you just
so to get off it i quit the daytime i
didn't do what you did like
you know three [__] pills throughout
the day a small amount i just cleaned
myself out of
doing nothing in the daytime
and i would just taper off at night
and now i feel great
it's been two [__] different worlds
not how i feel
but it's amazing
the anxiety that you [__] get
from the xanax because once you you
start eating the xanax to go down
but then
you eat the xanax and you go up
that's what was happening to me i was
really spinning out of control
so i don't listen man i was always under
the impression if you bought a [__]
pill on the street it was bad for you
i thought if a doctor gave you something
you were okay
i found out about the xanax after i was
in already deep i didn't i had no idea
that you'd get hooked i had no idea that
it [__] with your gaba receptors
i had no [__] idea that you know i
was gonna get depressed and go down and
you know lose weight i had no [__]
idea so
before you eat [__] xanax you better
think twice [__] because that
[__]
will double up on you and next thing you
know you're [__] living that anxiety
it's just running you it's a [__]
nightmare i had to stop smoking pot and
everything
because it would just kick up the
anxiety stopped drinking espressos i
stopped everything cold turkey
and then i tape it off safely and here
we are today [__] august 10th
of 2021 you know but [__] that was a
nightmare there was no withdrawals with
cocaine there was no withdrawals with
reefer
there was no withdrawals with nothing
xanax was a complete different [__]
story
so
if you're on xanax you better start
tapering [__] because it's going
to take you somewhere where you don't
want to be
it takes you into the [__] murky
waters let me ask you this why haven't
you moved to new york you want to stay
in la right now because you were saying
you signed the lease and you didn't know
and
yeah i just suddenly so i'm i'm doing my
uh my podcast though with jamie and
kasim and it's like
right now jamie's in austin and me and
kasem do it out of la and he has like a
little studio in his house that we do it
out of so it's if i like the feeling of
at least two of us being together and
one being away we're like if all three
of us are in totally different cities
and we're doing it over zoom it's like
you know
it's just not something i i get i love
doing the podcast and i don't want it to
become a thing where it's like uh you
know the passion goes away or this i
feel like when
when you know you got three people and
none of you are in the same room
especially when you know six months ago
we were in the same room every [__]
episode so we know that energy you know
we knew what it was like then
and then you moved to one person being
away and you're like all right we could
still manage we could still do it where
in my head i'm like
if all three of us are in different
[__] cities but also
i just i hate the winter man i hate it i
and i hate flying so people are like oh
live in new york for [__] this amount
of time and then fly to [__] you know
florida or l.a and i'm like i don't want
to i don't want to be counting down how
long again until and then what am i
going to do rent my [__] apartment in
the city and i'm like this is all
too much for me i'm like just for now
you know i got another year here figure
it out
uh
you know i'm not if i had three more
friends moved to austin
i i would be uh
i'd be down to check out austin for a
year something like that but uh
yeah again it's like
if i'm not living in new york i don't
care where the [__] i am it's it's all
it's all the same to me like it's new
york and then i'm somewhere else you
know
do you miss new york at all
every day i miss new york more than i
miss anyone in my [__] family like
you know because new york new york to me
is all of that like i grew up in
manhattan i so it's like when i drive
over that bridge and then all of a
sudden i'm [__] you know
driving in a in a cab to go home it's
like every block i look at i'm like oh
that's where [__] alex got in the
fight with this guy this is where
[__] marcelo lost his virginity like
this is that and just driving down the
[__]
street it's like oh my god and
my parents
uh grew up on like the same on 83rd
street between first and second where i
grew up so it's like i'm you know their
history my history this going into
[__] you know like i got a italian
restaurant to lizzie is on 92nd and 2nd
that i [__] walk into and it's like
it's more
it doesn't compare to one [__] place
out here you know people talk about like
oh have you been to this italian
restaurant out here it's it's the best
out here this and you go and you go yeah
it's not even an average italian place
in new york
like it's just it's like yeah they can
fry a [__] chicken cullet and throw
red sauce on it and it's it doesn't
taste bad like it wouldn't taste bad if
i made it either but
it's not even close like
this place that i go to in new york that
i've been going to forever it's like
somehow you tell them like
you could get penne aloe vodka [__]
chicken parm sausage and peppers and
you're like how is this incredible
no one's ever heard this play and you're
like because that's new york you know
out here if they were making that food
there would be a line of jerk offs
[__] 300 long instagram in it and
like taking pictures with the [__]
chicken cutlet in their mouth and this
at this place no one's ever i've never
heard one person bring this place up to
me in [__] in new york anything and
for me it's like i i as soon as i get
home i'm like i gotta go right here like
i [__] love it because
there's a thousand places like that in
new york you know where just the average
place a place that you like to go to
you're like yo i know the penne a levati
here is better than what people [__]
talk about in la is like oh my god like
this is you know hashtag eat yummy yummy
and i'm like what the [__] are you
talking about like this is
fine but it's like their whole world you
know
i do not miss la at
all can you believe that
like that was one of the saddest things
to me like i had
i was sad when i first got here i was
sad over two things one
that i did not miss la any of it
and b
i didn't miss doing stand-up
like those two things bothered me so
much i had to talk to a therapist
because i did not miss la at all i kept
thinking to myself what the [__]
is wrong with me
but there was nothing about l.a towards
the end that i missed
i didn't miss the shitty [__] food
i didn't miss i i didn't miss any of
that stuff and you're right here
i'm in south jersey i'm in an area where
a lot of staten island people moved into
the new jersey people complain about
them you know because they've been here
all their life all these people from
staten island
these people from staten island have
brought food to south jersey
that would make your [__] quiver
you know like the [__] chicken palm
the
there's italian restaurants i mean
there's not a bad slice of pizza around
here
like people oh i drove to edison i drove
here for pizza go [__] yourself you you
could drive down the corner to dinos and
it's [__] great pizza you know
um
but that's one thing i do not miss the
little
the affair with amazing that is la you
know everything is amazing but it
[__] blows
you know you wait online for something
or you wait to go get something the only
thing i do miss is my weed store let's
cut this [__] i miss ice cream shop
i miss my [__] wheat store i
miss the girls in there
i do miss cryotherapy
the whole concept of crowd therapy here
in new jersey i think cryotherapy is
going into a box with your head out you
know they don't know
the whole you walk in the [__] eye
goggles the ear stuff you know i miss
those things i miss a few of my friends
but besides that it's not i don't miss
la how i thought i would miss it i
thought like i was gonna be heartbroken
to store and all that no i came to terms
with it
and uh i feel a lot better that i'm here
i really do feel a lot better than i'm
here this you know i could have gone to
austin but i i think that deep down in
the side i just wanted it to just end
you know like comedy
i enjoy doing the podcast i really do
you know but
i don't want a big scale podcast ever
again
you know i like what i'm doing now you
know i'm lucky we didn't move into a
studio yet
because the numbers are going up who the
[__] knows where we're gonna be
by the end of the year or by november or
september who the [__] knows you know
like i said like we said in the
beginning of this we're just living
day to [__] day i'm gonna tell you
what made me go up there to get the
vaccine shot
i dumped an ounce of coke in 1986 i had
an ounce of coffee
and i went
me and my girlfriend went to get it
and then my girlfriend had to go home to
her parents house and she goes don't
break into that bag
till i get back to you tonight well let
me know when you get into the bag i'll
stop and get booze and come over
so i'm at this [__] random hotel room
in denver i just pick a hotel room that
i could afford
and i'm in there in austin i go let me
do a bump
and i start bumping she's calling me i'm
not answering the phone because i had
the mickey mouse voice i mean i would
get this little mickey mouse voice when
i did coke and she would know
so
you know
when you eat coke it's it [__] it
makes your tonsils swell or it closes
your thing so your voice or that would
always happen to me especially when i
put a coke rock
in my mouth i get a freeze this was like
the worst day of my life i started
snorting like a two in the afternoon and
i heard like a drill
i kept hearing the drills
i'm like it's the dea
drilling to put like a [__]
eyeball on me through the wall and [__]
so i couldn't take it no more i started
looking out the window
and it would be a car would come and
stop there for like three minutes then
take off this kept happening i'm like
this the fbi switching cars
so i went in the bathroom and i dumped
the [__] ounce of coke the worst
thing i did was there was a pitcher
of water and i put a coke rock in there
to see how long it would take the coke
rock to melt just in case somebody
kicked down the door
and i'll never forget that
eventually my head won and i ended up
dumping the ounce of coke in the toilet
and flushing it
i must have dumped 25 grams of coke in
there and the oh in the in the
toilet and when i flushed it
the coke came back up in the water and
it stayed on the walls of the toilet
so now i'm coming down
and i'll never forget being on my hands
and knees and looking at a hotel toilet
you could see the [__] around the bottom
of the rim and
and i'm over there licking pieces off
the toilet
and putting it on my tongue and putting
it in my nose
like a [__] disgusto that i am
so after i thought of that story i'm
like why wouldn't i be getting my
vaccine i [__] stuck my finger
in a [__] toilet i remember one time
i was doing coke of the urinal and the
coke fell into the urinal and before the
biscuit hit it i took the coke out of
the [__] urinal and i started doing
it before it would [__] melt i had
you know 200 people's piss on my [__]
hand and i just washed it off and went
and did what i did you know so
we do all these disgusting things and
then to say that you don't want to
[__] put something in your body
it just doesn't make sense to me you
know especially when you've done illegal
drugs and god knows what else
so
i used to have a guy who would bring me
percocets and he so
my uh
i grew i grew up on like around 92nd but
then i moved to back to 83rd and then i
moved back to 91st street so i was on my
place on 91st and 1st
and my buddy actually lived in the
neighborhood but he would come like he'd
always be you know delivering [__] to
people so
he showed up at my place one time and he
would [__] they're like don't get
high on your own supply he was the
[__] he was high from the time he
[__] woke up till he went to bed and
just kept getting worse and worse and
you know rest in peace he passed away
but he uh
and he's younger than me too it's [__]
up
but he one time he showed up to my
there were two times one time he showed
up to my apartment he buzzed up
i'm like yeah hello i talked to the
doorman it's like yeah your boy's here
i'm like alright set him up i hang up
like 15 minutes later he's still nowhere
to be found
like it takes 30 [__] seconds to get
to the doorman to hear so finally like
uh he shows up i go or it might have
even been like two days later he caught
and i'm like yo what happened you buzzed
up the other night and you didn't come
up he's like oh i got into a fight with
your doorman
i'm like how do you the exchange to the
doorman to you it hey can you buzz rob
he's in uh you know 4a yeah okay all
right yeah he's okay he's on the way up
like thanks and that's it
how in that time you can get into a
fight still blows my mind this is like
[__] 15 years later i'm like how the
[__]
how in that can you possibly get into a
fight with somebody then
another time
uh he buzzes up i don't he's not there
for like 10 minutes i'm like where the
[__] i look into the hallway and he's
standing so we used to get these
sandwiches like chopped cheese
sandwiches and they're like uh they're
like a cheeseburger but on a hero and
they would be like [__] 99 cents we'd
always be like how did they make [__]
cheeseburgers on heroes for 99 cents
and i opened the door and i looked down
the hallway and he's standing in the
hallway with his eyes closed eating a
[__] chopped cheese sandwich
i'm like yo what are you doing like get
in here you know so he comes in but uh
my point was he told me that day that he
walked from the the train station on
86th and lex to my place on 91st and
first with his eyes closed
i was like how are you not [__] dead
like cross and shoulders like i don't
know but again the reason why i was
reminded that you brought this up is
when i would get percocets from him i'd
be like how many do you want i'd tell
him and he would just start reaching in
his pocket he'd pull out [__] money
band-aids this and he'd start pulling
out loose
percocet pills and just put him on the
table and he'd be all like pulling out
other pills i don't know what this is
can you google this like look this [__]
up i don't know and it was just every
like you know pieces of like the top of
a [__] straw like you know when you
you're at a diner and you pull the
they give you the the the drink with the
straw with a little bit of paper still
on top like there would be that balled
up in his pocket he'd pull that [__] up
just everything he'd put on the table
and i didn't like back then i didn't
even think
like oh this is disgusting you know
whatever i'd be so excited that he was
because when you deal
like for my personal history when i
dealt with like uh
the coke dealers
they said i'm gonna be there at this
time they they were they were good
pretty close whatever uh weed guys are
not great but percocet there's nothing
like it like i had guys who i had we had
this kid i want to say his name so bad
because it's it's a funny nickname but i
i can't but uh
he
would tell you like oh i'm uh
i'm on my way
and [__] three hours later you
calling me like oh where are you he's
gone pulling up out i'm down i'm
downstairs right now i'm having a
problem with my girl like i'll be up in
10 minutes all right three hours later i
call yo where are you he's going walking
through your lobby like like right now
i'm like oh perfect i hang up [__]
two hours later i call like yo you just
said you were walking through he's gone
i'm in the elevator
i call him again an hour later he's like
oh i'm in your hallway like i open up
the door i'm like you're not in my
[__] hallway like where are you he'd
hang up and then i wouldn't hear from
him for [__] 24 hours and what he
would always do because i i he he was a
my buddy and i would see him do it to
other people is he would run out or he
wouldn't have enough and he wouldn't
want people going to [__] other
people to get it to get [__] better
prices or one day you know lose his
customers so he would say like uh i'd be
in the [__] car we'd be in atlantic
city playing [__] poker and he would
tell people yeah yeah i'm on [__]
83rd i'll be right there like you know
and he'd just be there with no intention
of ever [__] going there i'm like
hello why do you
[__] do this [__] he's like yo i
can't lose the custies like you know he
but i'm like these people hate you and
he's again until i [__] bring him you
know a hundred perks tomorrow and i give
it to him for a dollar less and i gave
it to him last time they forget all
about it i'm like yeah i know because i
do too you know like a [__]
like an idiot but
[__] dealers are on their own planet
aren't they
their own but in new york i gotta say in
new york city coke dealers for me
were always like yeah call there were
guys you'd call at midnight they'd be
there in 30 minutes guys you'd call it 9
a.m they'd be there in 30 minutes as
long as they knew like yeah you didn't
just want to grab a [__] gram or
whatever like you were really gonna buy
something they were
they for me they were always good weed
guys uh you know suck and they're on
their own planet and then [__]
opiates man forget it like you just
there would be time
three days later he would show up like
oh sorry and just and never they
wouldn't even put in the effort of like
you know i got arrested or or this
[__] happened you know they would be
like oh i got in a fight with my girl
and you're like
three days you told me you were in the
lobby like what are you talking it was
so [__] frustrating man but
especially when you're [__] meeting
opiates you know and you're like oh i
got i got [__] three left bro where
are you and he's like i'm around the
corner you know
i'll tell you i don't miss dealers at
all i miss them because you got a good
laugh from them
hey i had i had an armenian guy in la
that was a [__] riot
he was a [__] riot i still remember
him bringing me eight balls
and going do you want it down
and i'm like a damn
what's it done he goes you know down to
when you you get cooked out do you you
could go down i go yeah what do you got
valium whatever he goes i don't know
give me like four pills and i'm like
what are they he goes i don't know
my friend gave them to me i give to you
i'm like that's not good enough
you know and he would say they [__] you
up whatever and then you still go on
pill finder on webmd and the pill would
have no record in there i'm like what
are you giving me where do you get the
oh that's for mother mania what the [__]
i'm on webmd which is [__] america i
had another dealer in jersey
when i not when i first moved here like
throughout the years when i come back
and do comedy he was up in north bergen
and i still remember calling him
telling him i'm outside him going come
to the side of the house and i'm like
why
and he would lower the coke on a little
[__] glass boat
down the window
and i would be there waiting and i'll
say you'd see this little boat this
little miniature [__] boat coming
down
i'd take the coke out and i put the
fifty dollars and they'd [__] carry
it back up the [__] i mean true you know
you can't write that [__] you can't
write that [__] but that's
drug dealers i had a guy in la that
didn't have a phone number
and i go how do i get a hold of you and
he'd go just go by uh
what's the what are the places where all
the mexicans hang out in front home
depot
yeah there's one on there's one on
sunset
like but past kaiser
and he he would say just come
to this neighborhood and drive on sunset
and i'll find you
you know how many nights i went there at
three in the morning and drove down
made a u-turn and he would like come i
think he lived in a tree
like he lived on the [__] west it was
on western western and sunset there's a
mcdonald's there it's down the block
from [__] kaiser to and the
scientology if you headed towards the
beach
he would be living in that [__]
parking lot because every time i would
make a u-turn you'd go to the light
and also he'd pop out in the street and
he wouldn't say hello or anything he
would knock on the glass you lowered
your glass and the first thing he did
was put a coke rock in your nose
he wouldn't even say a word just to
double check that you were in a cop
he would put a coke rock in your nose
without asking your permission
one minute you were opening the glass
the next minute he was putting a coke
rock in your nose and then you would ask
him he would say what do you want in
spanish you get you tell him seventy
dollars worth and he'd go put your hand
out
so i'd have to drive with the coke on
sunset in the palm of my [__] hand
like i'm delivering a pizza because i
didn't want it to put somewhere and then
fall and it would start to melt because
your palms are sweaty it was a [__]
nightmare but looking back on it now
it was a [__] pisser what you do
deal with with [__] drugs it really
is crazy
and like you said the uh i remember
guys always coming through with like
pills and they didn't know what it was
and then like there were sometimes i
remember
going to google it and then going like
what [__] shape is this like i don't
even know what is this a rhomboid like
you know you're like what is this a
hexagon like i don't even and they're
like oh and then you got [__] eight
people on drugs sitting around being
like no i think that's a [__]
isosceles trying you know like you're
like i don't know what the what is this
thing you know and you're trying to
[__] find it you can't find it i
remember one time
i was at an after hours at somebody's
house in vegas and i was [__] sitting
talking to this girl
uh and we're by like the foot of the bed
and i remember looking like on you could
see under the bed and there was a
[__] pill over there and without
skipping a beat i just [__] while
talking to her i leaned over i grabbed
it i [__] popped it in my mouth and
like i was drinking tequila i took it
back and she was like what was that i'm
like i don't [__] no idea who gives a
[__] yeah we'll find out maybe in like
30 minutes
[Laughter]
it's crazy how you don't have fear
like i didn't have fear of drugs
i was so confident in my drug use i had
no fear of what i was eating
or putting up my nose you take it for
granted then you [__]
you know years later like now i sit here
at night and i'm like i can't even
imagine having a drink
i can't even imagine doing a line of
coke now i think i would have a heart
attack right off the bat if you showed
me coke i think i would die
i was always
somebody who wasn't scared of drugs the
only thing i was scared of was edibles
that was the only [__] that ever put me
somewhere where i was like i can't
handle this like i like i [__] did
acid or out of [__] not even looking
at how much it was [__] the first
time i took shrooms i took seven grams
so every time after that i would take
seven grams or more and i was like 16 on
my birthday it was [__] so every time
i did and they were [__] like blue
caps too i was on another [__] planet
my friend this girl threw up a match
like she figured out that after she's
like oh i must have drank like
like a can of beer or something that
somebody put a [__] match in or
whatever but she was like i'm not
feeling good and everybody like when
you're
if you're drunk and you're throwing up
you're like i want to be alone when
you're on mushrooms you're like yeah
what can we do for you you know you
wanna we'll put your [__] feet in a
in a in a warm bath while you're
throwing up you know whatever you want
and she's like uh over the toilet and
she starts throwing up and just a
[__] like burnt match
she showed up in the toilet and we
[__] laughed forever man but like
the only [__] i ever had a bad
uh and like coke yeah i always hear in
movies like oh this is how much coke you
could do i'm like really cause i think
it's a lot more like i i don't ever and
then people were saying like
you could get poisoning from [__]
aspirin this and i'm like i had times
where i took 30 vicodin like and and
there was no so what i don't know i just
you hear the [__] and you're like okay
like i i guess it sounds right but
edibles and va if i took one value i was
rocked like valium just didn't agree
with me for some reason but like
anything else did edibles for me would
put me it was the only time i was ever
on drugs where i was like i just want
this to stop like
please like i just i need it to stop i
was never in my life on
coke
ecstasy ma this where i was like i want
i wanted to end like you know like
please like i'll do anything just make
it go away you know there were hangovers
where i felt that way you know where i
was like please i just can't i can't
handle this anymore you know i'm [__]
puking up black stuff for [__] three
days you know i can't eat anything i
can't drink anything that that was when
i was like i can't handle this
especially like
when i i went to vegas for two weeks and
i stayed for like
under two years i think it was like uh
18 months whatever it was but like i
some of the nights partying there
and just being alone and waking up alone
you're in the [__] dry
desert and i had like floor-to-ceiling
windows and you'd fall asleep with the
[__] the curtain open and you'd wake
up with the [__] 7am vegas sun just
blasting you in the face you wake up
you're like i'm not home you get so
[__] dry and you're [__] throwing
up and you're like this is
the word i just hated for some reason
being
hung over in new york was easier for me
than [__] vegas i don't know if it's
the dry if it's just from like
the [__] strippers every night and
being like i don't know what something
about vegas those hangovers would just
be vicious
oh that's the reason why i quit because
i cannot deal with [__] hangovers
that was my that was it
i couldn't deal with hangovers so that's
why i stopped the drinking and the
coking and
the whole [__] thing
what did you feel it now
how am i feeling now
i'm feeling good now
i've been here 11 months now and i
finally started feeling good about three
or four weeks ago
you know i did a bunch of tests to see
what was going on blood test and uh
it was basics basically the withdrawals
from xanax
when i started tapering again and then
uh
everything came back i'm okay i feel a
lot better
i feel a lot [__] better
i take care of myself i've been sleeping
well i've been eating good you know i've
been working out like a [__] lunatic
um
and just being a dad
and that's been uh great lately it
agrees a lot with me so
maybe it's time for you to get married
and have some kids mr hyla
ah i don't know i think i'm [__] too
selfish with my time like i i i remember
like
i was watching like the nba finals
or whatever and i called one of my
buddies who we used to talk about
basketball all the time like did you see
that [__]
game or whatever and he started laughing
i'm like well he's like i have two
daughters and one you know one is eight
one is four whatever he's like you know
the last time i watched what i wanted to
watch on tv was he's like
unless they're sleeping and then i just
want to go to bed he's like they if i'm
watching tv in the living room they come
out of the living room they jump on me
oh i want [__] peppa pig whatever you
know kids are watching and then he's
like so i'll put it on as soon as i
think i could slip away i go in the
other room and start watching tv and
then they're in there in [__] 60
seconds jumping on me hopping them it's
like they know you know they he's like i
don't
and he's like you know
once you go through three weeks of that
the first three weeks he goes i just
gave up he's like now i just sit there
and i [__] all i watch is cartoons
and i do this and i don't you know
jamie
uh
she talks about it on on the podcast but
she was dealing uh with stuff with and
again like you talked about it was
definitely from
her her son was two years old in la and
they didn't leave the house for [__]
months because of covid and there was no
school and there was this so you know
she was dealing with him that they're
like oh you have [__]
uh is it this you have to go see doctor
with the kid is it sensory issues is it
is it that and you know what's funny is
like none of the doctors are like yeah
it's [__] being locked up in a house
for
for [__] six months when you're at
the craziest time of growing
in your life you're [__] two years
old everything you see is supposed to be
new he's like he he's the only
two-year-old who's like sick of what
he's looking at you know like he's
walking around the house he's like yeah
i know like mom's here [__] dad's
here the dog's here whatever so they
went to austin but
it made me think of like
i don't know if i want kids if
everything turns out perfect you know
god forbid i i [__] have a problem
with the chick or the kid has issues and
this and now that becomes my life and
i'm like man i don't i think i just
i [__] love my
my time man my free time but
i don't know maybe i'll meet the right
girl and that'll go away i don't know
it was always a pleasure man it's always
a pleasure to see you always a pleasure
to talk to you
when we text and stuff at night it's
always great
thank you for making time for me this
week buddy that was a great [__]
podcast i love all that [__] i loved
anytime man i'm i'm fight like you know
with you and christina p is the same way
like when you guys ask me about the
podcast and you're like oh thank you and
this i'm like thank you i [__] love
doing it and i don't know if it's like
because i watched so much of your
podcast before we met or because of like
the east coast vibe or what it is but
it's like
we only hung out a couple times in
person and i feel like i've known you
forever
forever yeah it's one of those things
where you're just like okay and that's
you know there's so many people who like
you know they're like uh
you meet joey diaz there's nobody like
him like and for me growing up in new
york i'm like i see joey diaz and i'm
like oh like you know like this it makes
me feel at home you know it i'm not like
it's it's just yeah it's nice man it's a
very you know you you there's a lot of
people and i'm probably one of them
where like
i'm out in la i'm from new york somebody
could not know that you know they could
see me and be like oh this guy is
[__]
from la or whatever he's drinking a
[__] green juice and doing [__]
yoga or whatever but it's like you you
never lost it for one second you know as
soon as you there's no uh
like you know guess where i'm from you
know
i love it i made sure that i didn't lose
it you know i made sure i talked to my
friends
i kept that new york state of mind and i
[__] you know i'm like you i'm a new
yorker man you can't take that away from
anybody i moved to jersey in 73
but for those first seven years i lived
in [__] manhattan on 88th street so
we got the [__] juice and i used to
run and harlem so
you know how we do it man but it's
always a pleasure
keep me posted and stay in touch you
know i love you with all my heart
yeah man love you too it's great to see
you thanks for having me on
abso [__] lutely and we'll talk next
week all right buddy all right thank you
for always keeping in touch with me love
you my man love you man
all right i hope you enjoyed the episode
with rob robert we talked about a lot of
weird [__]
[__] uh licking [__] cocaine from
a toilet
it's the truth why would i lie to you
[__] there was a couple of
pubic hairs in there there was [__]
around the brim there was piss
but i did it so
this is why today i'm a [__] savage
you know besides swimming in the hudson
and [__] like that how can i not take
the [__] vaccine after [__]
thinking about that you figure it out
i'm sure a lot of you [__] guys
did some crazy [__] things i don't
know if you have a lick coke from a
toilet bowl but hey whatever it's
[__] experience and that's what we're
talking about today whether it's the
comedy experience or the life experience
we got a more [__] cupboard to you
thank you very much for watching this
week's joint
uh thank you for the support and thank
you for supporting laughing gas it
should be back
at the ice cream cake this week
if not check out next week it should be
back there i haven't talked i haven't
spoken to them in a few days but i'll
check in with them today after we do
wrap this [__] up i love you
guys i'll see you next monday morning
tip top magoo ready to go
and now for a word for my [__]
sponsors jack all right i want to thank
my man robert eiler i want to thank mike
i want to thank you [__]
but most importantly i want to thank you
guys for the support and love that you
give us every week
you know what man we're slipping but
you're still there and that's why i love
you [__] so before you leave do
me a favor
i want to talk to you about the sponsors
this week
the first one cbd lion tremendous when
it comes to cbd
you're left there scratching your head
it's all over the place nobody knows
what to get let your uncle joey [__]
guide you like i do for the [__]
reefer cbd lion is the best cbd
available to you
they have in every different form for
kinesiology tape to roll on to gummy
bears to
the vapor pen
the back balls i mean if cbd lion don't
have it it's not around it's that simple
go to cbdlion.com right now read the
third party lab results they'll let you
know what your ailment is and what you
need
to help you with that ailment whether
it's anxiety pain
knee pain whatever it is cbd lion walk
me through the surgery they could do the
same for you but it all starts by you go
on the cbd line reading the third party
lab results and when you order do not
forget the press and joey or code church
to receive 20 percent off delivered
right to your house cbd lion the best
cbd on the market
the joint is also brought to you by
stamps.com
the summer has been tremendous so far
we're enjoying life's [__] pleasures
block parties barbecues little league
games bikinis but going back to the post
office is not one of them with
stamps.com you can skip the post office
and save
money on postage you could send letters
and packages anytime anywhere right from
your computer you could buy print or
ship it's that simple with stamps.com
you pay a whole lot less you get
discounts up to 40 percent from the post
office rates and up to 66 percent from
ups who could do that for you nobody
stamps.com
saves businesses thousands of hours and
loads of cash
we've been on stamps.com close to 10
years now my wife and i
we my wife loves it it's it's simple
you measure your own stuff you put it
out by the post office you put it up by
the by the mailbox and they do the rest
you got a small business i don't care
how small it is stamps.com is a
must-have you can print postage for any
letter any package any class of mail
it's no wonder over a million small
businesses i've already used
stance.com ship anywhere in the world
straight from your laptop you schedule a
pickup and the mailman comes to you
who's better than you
nobody if you're not with stamps.com
you're slipping so stop wasting time
going to the post office go to
stamps.com instead it's no risk use
promo code joey to get your special
offer that includes a four-week trial
plus free postage and a digital scale
with stamps.com there's no long-term
commitments or contracts go to
stamps.com today click on the microphone
at the top of the home page and type in
joey j-o-e-y that stamps.com use promo
code joeystamps.com
never go to the post office again i want
to thank
stamps.com and i want to thank cbd lion
i also want to thank draftkings for
having our back on monday like i said
college football is around the corner
one dollar when you 200
in credits if you bet one dollar on any
college game
draftkings is gonna give you two hundred
dollars to black the rest of the season
use promo code joey i love all you
[__]
i want to thank cbd lion
draftkings i want to thank
stamps.com i want to thank all these for
supporting the joint i'll see you monday
nice and early
tip top magoo stay black i love you have
a great weekend
[Music]
it's over but the shouting
you got this [__]
[Music]
so
you